hello everyone uh welcome to high data
global 2021
uh i am conrad ho uh one of the chairs
of this conference
uh we're very happy to welcome calyan
today
he is a self-taught data scientist
who is also a core member and meet-up
organizer and a committee member of
pycon hibernate and india
um here to talk to us about newer profit
thank you please take it away thank you
for the warmer introduction uh hey folks
uh i'm kalyan prasad today i'm going to
talk about uh usual profit powerful ai
from framework for time series model uh
before i actually jump into my actual
presentation i would like to sincerely
thank and give credits to the
oscar trey who is the author of a neural
profit for creating an amazing tool for
time series models
so
here's a quick intro about me uh yeah
i'm a celtic data scientist analytics
manager currently working with one of
the startup based in hyderabad and i
also love involving the different
communities and i love helping
communities uh in multiple ways uh
currently i'm associated with the
following organizations
with the following organizations uh so
where i have different roles and
different responsibilities uh altogether
and i also love to give back to
communities always so i always look for
opportunities uh to share my knowledge
uh that's pretty much about me uh so
here is the agenda for today's talk uh
we'll start with a quick intro to time
series then we'll see uh what is another
profit and why we actually need your
profit and what is the difference
between the original profit and general
profit then we straight away jump into
action to see
the power of neural profit and i'll wrap
up my talk accordingly so feel free to
uh post your questions at any point of
time i'll definitely answer each and
every question
as much as i can
without any further delays let's get
started
uh time series so there are so many
definitions of the time series which are
available on the internet orders which
indicate same meaning in a different way
a pretty straightforward definition e
sequential data order matters
a time series is a sequence of
observation taken sequentially in time
when you are forecasting uh time series
data the main aim is to estimate how
sequence of observation will continue in
future
so observations are typically collected
at regular intervals like you know every
day every week yearly monthly etc
for example if you are talking about
weather data we may receive weather
updates for every 10 minutes or every
hour or if you are talking something
about iot sensors like that that
generate the data continuously so
depending upon the source of the
generation we may have different
frequencies at which data is collected
advancements in machine learning have
increased the value of time series
because there are so many prediction
problems that involve time component
that is why it is like booming in the
industry now
organizations also apply machine
learning to time series data to do
forecasting they also compare the
seasonal and cyclic patterns because
time series forecasting helps us to
predict the future values of a critical
field which has a potential business
value in the industry for example
predicting the health condition of a
person or predicting the performance of
a player or predicting the performances
sport based on the previous performance
or previous played data
believe that time series has literally
spread his wings across fda so that is
why it is
everywhere
now here comes our main topic neural
profit so here is a quick visual uh
representation about neural profit so it
is a python library for time series
modeling data and neural profit is a
neural network based model that uses a
python framework as a packet and it has
a modular architecture that allows so
many futures to be plotted in the future
and this library is heavily inspired
from facebook profit and air net library
the
the authors of this library are the
research from the stanford university in
collaboration with monash university
and what more you need to know about
neural profit
this library is a beginner friendly and
you can easily one can easily set up and
get start building and start building a
time series model
it also addresses main points such as
scaling customization and extensibility
with this library you can easily cast
scale your model can be completely
scalable and you can also customize or
you know adjust your model according to
your needs of course without changing
the core code base you can also edit or
manipulate the code
it's amazing
just like profit neural profit is also
decomposable with all time series
components like you know trend
seasonality auto represents feature
such as review air network for time
series forecasting
now why we actually need a neural
profile i mean like what is the power of
neural property it aims to solve the
sees of uncertainty
what do i mean by this point
i guess you are already aware of
autoregressive models autoregressive
models are nothing new but you would
usually use linear fit with a least
square instead of a neural network with
back propagation
watering this neural network mimics the
traditional ar process within neural
network so it is a single layer network
that is trained to mimic the air process
in a time series signal at a very large
scale comparatively with traditional
models
auto air net also scales much better to
the larger data set and more input for
example
if you look at this below graph we can
see that the training time of air net
doesn't increase exponentially with the
air order
and another important thing which i
would also like to mention here is about
the p values so p values here are the
number of order regressives used in the
auto industry models not those pros
which we use in the hypothesis this is
something you should remember here
neural profit also updates profit linear
external degrees to feed forward in the
networks because deeper equals to better
so the deeper the fee for networks that
the better our model is fast and the
better we have results and accuracy
that's the power of a neural profile
again adding neural networks to the
profit has a downside because the amount
of a learning parameter increased
dramatically
to sync with that url profit uses by
touch framework as a back-end instead of
a stand and it trades with the
stochastic gradient descent which is an
amazing thing about the neural profit
now here comes the
difference between the original profit
and the neutral profit okay
when you are exploring time series data
or your learning time series data at any
point of time definitely you will
encounter a popular package called
facebook profit
the reason is that
it has gained a lot of popularity
due to the fact that
it provides a very good performance in
terms of accuracy and interpretable
business
the best part of facebook profit is it
also automate a lot of elements such as
hyperparameter tuning
or
feature engineering for the users that
is why facebook profit is a pretty
straightforward to use for a data
scientist or any other folks who are
playing with the time series data or
even for the folks who has a very less
technical knowledge
when coming to neural profit the author
also had same thing in mind by retaining
all the advantages of the profit by by
focusing improving the accuracy and
scalability
so using ar net to scale
the of the neural networks with the
interpretive of autoregressive models
so these are some of the core
differences on the futures which are
existed in your profit comparatively
with the facebook profit
it's like radiant decent for
optimization since mule profit uses a
python framework as a backend and it
trains with the stochastic radiations
and which makes our modelling much
faster
time series autocorrelation is modeled
using the autoregressive neural network
so this is again an amazing thing here
our lagged resources are trained using a
separate field for our networks
additionally our model is also
configurable to non-linear d layers of
the feed forward network so this is
again the amazing feature which is
exchanging your profit the best part is
it also offers a lot of custom metrics
and losses
from this great features another thing
on the great feature of a general profit
is
it giving developer access to the kmt
library which was developed by facebook
so that's that's pretty that's the
amazing thing about neural profit so i
think i have given so much enough
download on theory so
let's jump into action to see
how real profit works in a real time so
let me switch back to my code notebook
now
so
so here's a
notebook for this presentation so the
goal of this notebook is to show you how
your profit used for a forecasting time
series model
and uh we'll see that in a while so
and
before i walk through the presentation
code and let me tell you something here
so i have already executed the entire
code for this demonstration in order to
save in order to save time because it
takes some it takes a couple of times to
execute the work so instead of wasting
time i have already executed i explain
each and every part of the code however
i would also run a few snippets to show
you some cool stuff uh and this uh in
this demonstration
okay when it comes to installation of
regular profit there are multiple ways
you can do it you can simply install or
you can if you want to run your profit
in a jupiter notebook you need to
install in your profit line because this
will enable live plots for both or not
training and validation cost
orange if you want to have an up-to-date
version of a neural profit simply go to
the github repository and clone the
repository and start playing with it so
it's up to you how you want to do it so
in my case i have installed the live one
in the notebook here
so which is already done so basically
this notebook has been classified into
two sections in the first section we'll
simply see how to create a simple
baseline model using neural profile in
the next section we'll dig into big
detail about neural profit to see some
additional information or internet stuff
involved in the neural profit
okay so as usual will import messages
suspects uh here so i have done the same
thing and from neural profit i have
inputted random seed as well so i'm
setting my random sale with the random
number to make sure that no results are
reproducible when every time our
model runs here
so i'm taking the retail sales cs csv
data from our newer profit github page
so i've just executed that read the data
so here are the first windows and uh
here the last channel is our data
so just like profit neural profit also
also requires to do some reformatting on
our data frame before we pass it to our
model so all we need to make sure that
you know our date is your correct data
and it should be named as a ts and our
prediction parameter should be named as
y so in our case we have already done
that so we don't need to do any
reformation free formatting here so we
are good to proceed further
so so we can we can simply create a
model and validate in your profit with
very few lines of it code so this you
see now so i have initiated my neural
profit model here uh and there are so
many options and parameters which can
also pass in this model to improve that
is improve evacuation or improve the
results of regular market but however
for this time for the movement and we
keep things simple and we'll simply run
a baseline model so i'm not passing any
parameters here so
okay then i'm fitting my model to
moderating my model passing my data and
also a couple of parameters here so
validate feature which is nothing but
whether to validate the model data on
model performance on validation data for
each epoch so value b is nothing but it
is a floating point between the zero and
one uh
so indicating that the distribution
should be
used for training
the proportion of the data should be
used for the training
lot life loss so which will enable to
show you the live plot for now training
in validation which you will see
now
epoxy is nothing but the number of
effort that should be used for training
here so once i execute please just
observe this live plot
it should take a few
seconds to
run
um
okay notice uh notice how our plot and
last values are changing after each
epoch so if you remember just just again
uh just just focus again that you know
uh observe that how our plot and loss
values are updating after each above
this is what you see in this plot
okay yeah just observe that you know
yeah this is this is something amazing
here and also generating prediction is
also very straightforward so in order to
generate conditions in your profit you
need to create a feature data frame so
as the name suggests we need to create a
data new data frame of the date that
extends our original data from so this
is exactly what i am doing here so i'm
i'm creating my future data frame
passing my data and also giving a period
of 365 meaning that i'm creating a one
year feature data frame on my existing
data frame
then i'm passing my feature data frame
to predict function to written our
forecast so once i execute this they
require a feature data frame so just in
case if you are not sure just in case if
you are get confused whether it is a
data frame or not just go and check our
original data so gmail data has started
at 1992 0 1 1 january and our data frame
ended at uh
may 1st 2016. and if you see our future
data from it started at the may 2nd 2016
and it has ended at 2017.5 may 1st so
again one-year data another thing is it
also identifies the y-hat predictions
trend value and early seasonal value
which is really the amazing thing here
and it's also common that the y and
refrigerant value is to be named here so
this is uh this is an expected behavior
so you don't need to get finally when
you see such things
okay so we got a future data from so
let's plot our model now so let's plot
our model and see how the results are so
plotting our model is pretty
straightforward we just need to use the
model.plot function and pass our future
data frame and there you go and notice
how our model is able to learn the
seasonal parameters on our retail sales
data
and you can also plot the model plot
model components as well this is again a
pretty straightforward we need to call
the model.plot components and pass the
feature data frame there we get our you
know
model uh
what i mean uh the plot component values
have the plot component graphs as well
see so notice it shows a solid
decreasing brand for our retail data and
if you also look at the seasonal yearly
values and particularly if you observe
december being the busiest month that
comparatively with the other ones in the
retail csv data so this is this is how
you gain insights and these plot
components are really important for
domain experts because they visualize
this insight they will look into this
insight to understand the overall
forecasting process and the edges they
multiply accordingly so these product
components play a really key role uh for
the domain expense
so that's pretty much about you know uh
for creating a simple baseline model on
the neural profits so
now we'll jump into the next section in
this section we see why neural profit is
powerful so you know it is especially
powerful for time series forecasting
data because it takes additional
information into consideration such as
you know trend uh seasonality auto
regressors recurring events so we'll see
all of this additional information one
by one with the real-time example
so for this
this uh section i have taken you know
altogether a different data set from
kaggle one nifty fifty data sets one
that i have picked marthy company so i
have read the data so there we got our
first files of data and if you also look
at the info
so these are on the information about
the data frame
and we have put in 4
427 rows and 15 columns
on our data
so as i mentioned earlier we need to do
some reformatting on our data frame
before we pass it to our model so this
is exactly what i have done here so i've
selected my data frame and selected two
columns called date and vw ap vw ap is
nothing but a volume weighted average
price which is a trading benchmark for a
trader that gives an average price of a
security that has been traded throughout
the day based on the price and volume so
this price is really plays a key role
for the traders so i've selected that
column from marty stock
then since if you notice that you know
our date is an object column here so i
want my date to unit date time object so
that is what exactly i'm doing creating
applying my date to a periodic time
function this will convert my date from
object to a data date time once i
execute this so we got a date and
evaluated average size columns okay now
let's
you know start looking at our
additional information so we'll begin
with trends
now what are trends
a trend exists when there is a long term
increase or a decrease in the data so it
does not have to be linear always it
might change the direction from an
increasing trend to a decreasing trend
so what i'm doing is i've selected my
data frame here and selected a volume
rated average price and i'm simply
plotting it so
if you observe this visualization we can
see that it shows a general increasing
trend for our market stock price where
certain points a price rise and falls so
we consider these as i know we consider
those as our changing points with this
now what we do is we train our neural
profit model on our marquis stock price
by focusing only on the trend as our
first version of a model so meaning that
we
will be building our neural network
model
only focusing on the trend as our
first question so let's see that okay
before we uh start building our model so
we need to rename our columns so our
date column should be lds and our
parameters should be pi so this is what
i have done here resetting call and
renaming my columns there we got our
columns now we are good to proceed with
the modeling
so
now i have initiated my neural profit
model and i passed a couple of
parameters here so we will see what are
those and change points which is nothing
but specifying the number of points in a
broader trend so rate of increase or
decrease when the data changes so trend
is nothing but it's a regulation
parameter that controls the flexibility
of a changing point
and early season at a weekly seasonality
daily seasonality falls because we are
fully focusing on the trend so that's
the reason so
those parameters has been kept as a
false okay now we have initiated our
model
next i'm fitting my model and passed all
the parameters so you have seen all
these parameters in the first section so
there is no change in that so um
so again so i'll not explain the same
thing again here so let me run my live
plot again
so just notice that now how my live plot
changes here
see how the light lot is changing here
and how you gain insight from this
lifeboat so this is a very interesting
you know
uh with the light blocks
so
based on this slide plot it looks it
looks complete looks promising however
even after a lot of volatility you know
after a lot of volatility the model has
you know conversion
okay so if you if you didn't get this
point so let me let me let me explain in
a in in a better way so what we'll do is
so instead of understanding by this so
let's plot our model forecast plot to
understand how our model performs
so what i have done is i have created a
constant function called plot
forecast
we have passed a couple of parameters c
called model is nothing but our neural
profit model here data is nothing but
the data which we use for training it is
nothing but specifying the number of
pairs we want to forecast historic trade
is nothing but whether we want to plot
our model forecast on historical
predictions i will extend the step ahead
to
to show the forecast line uh so this is
the one this parameter is only used for
no autoregressive models only
so this is what i have created now
now what i'm doing here i'm creating my
future data frame here uh so i've
created my model dot mexican data frame
where i'm passing my data i'm giving my
periods and also giving my historical
prediction data so once i've created my
feature data frame i am patching my
feature data frame to predict function
to write in the forecast on the data
and also written a quick conditional
statement here which is like if higher
step head is not known so i want my
model to highlight the step of each of
the forecast line in the plot otherwise
simply just part the model forecast over
this is what exactly this little bit of
code here so
then i called my plot underscore
forecast function where i passed my
model with my pass my data frame and
given the period of 60 which is nothing
but also i want my model to predict
uh two months data so one side is given
this again so
so you will see we can now see our uh oh
we can now see our market stock prices
on the historical prediction as well as
our forecast data so by looking at this
visual so it is very clear that you know
our model is able to capture the general
increasing trend for our marathi
data
but however it seems to suffer
from with under fitting particularly you
know in the years of 2019 and 20 that
was likely used for validation
so you know so let's also look at the
forecast plot so this is again forecast
plot is also pretty simple right
hi kevin just a quick five minute award
yeah
okay
so so let's also look at the uh forecast
plot it also shows that no it seems it
shows that uh here historically false it
shows a solid increasing trend solid
increasing trend here so let me tell you
something if a stock price was that easy
to predict no one in the organization
would generally hire a financial advisor
unfortunately i'd rather to manage their
stock so this makes sense right so so
what we can do is we can scale our model
by considering seasonal parameters
seasonality parameters into the
consideration
i mean slices seasonality so now we are
training our modern signal the frame
parameters here now look at this uh so
if you look at this plot now so
our seasonality lot looks bit realistic
compared to what we have seen here but
however it still supports with some
under fitting here uh
and again if you look at our forecast of
seasonality plot it shows a smooth curve
but you hardly see the stock market more
very smooth most of the time if you
observe the stock market to look so
uneven and you know very confusing and
sometimes you also get scared by looking
at the stock market
so this is again so there is a problem
with here
now with air net life
the same review
now i'm trading our model so if you
observe our internet library track and
visualization the model looks a bit
realistic and it also able to capture
the movements of the stock market this
is again
this is again amazing so comparatively
with trend and season 90 auto regression
model has done a great job so what
abusive models are the class of models
that are able to capture
that are able to that are able to create
the future values of the variable based
on its past observation so we are
predicting uh for predicting here by
considering past historical data for two
months to predict the future historical
data so
this has done an amazing job here even i
also consider the recurring events into
the consideration we can also see the
plot so this is how the recurring event
plot looks like but however if i compare
that no there is no much change even
after taking recurring events into the
consideration
consideration so finally what i would
like to conclude here is uh
predicting a stock price is not that
easy in real time but however our model
has done the good job our air model has
done a good job in terms of capturing
the general increasing trend in the
stock market
uh to be on a solution site i generally
not recommend to use this model for your
own trading but i believe that this is a
good demonstration capabilities of you
know explaining with real profit in real
time and finally what i would like to
say is there is so much more you can do
with neural property for example you can
also explore with the auto regression
how would you traditionally work with
neural profits you can experiment that
but i think that you know this is plenty
that you at least you can get started
with the neural profit
with this uh let me switch to my slides
uh once uh and
so as i mentioned so mention that neural
profile is quite new library
there can be a lot of things in the
future and also uh so one thing you
should remember here is that not all the
features from the original profit are
already implemented in the newer profit
so they make it implement slowly and as
per the github documentation page so
these are some of the
current features which which will be
given to the future in the upcoming
versions of the individual property
logistics
uh
unless demand certainly execution
prevention values time free futurization
into model based modeling and on
supervisor detection these are some
amazing features i mean like
amazing features uh i know which we can
experiment in the general profit library
and uh here are the great references for
exploring your profit so this is the
documentation page and this is the auto
github repository and you can check some
amazing tutorials also they have and
this is the air net library uh yeah net
library page and this is a
good article between the difference
between the profit and your profit which
has written back on and this is again an
amazing thing
and
finally uh uh
thank you so much
i i
take the time understand so i respect
time uh in case if you have any feedback
you know or questions or any suggestions
for me feel free to reach out to me on
my social channels uh if you do
something i'm happy to address each and
everything and
thank you